good evening rent prices are rising in
las vegas and many just can't keep up
but help is here for some thanks for
joining us at 11 i'm denise valdez and
i'm brian loftis the spike in local
costs has left a lot of people without
answers or a place to call home
but one non-profit developer wants to
change that with a low-cost complex
right in the central valley
sasha loftis joining us now live tonight
near decatur and alto with more sasha
denise and brian with rent prices going
up over the last couple months many here
in the valley say it's just really
getting out of control
and they can't keep up that's the
problem that projects like this one
behind me hope to solve
they want to create clean safe options
for people making less money
as our economy bounces back rent prices
are on the rise
in las vegas everybody's kind of
struggling right now and those
skyrocketing rates
are leaving many out of options i have a
dear friend that's good
you know i don't know what's going to
happen to her enter
decatur commons a 480 unit affordable
housing community
under construction near alta and decatur
affordable housing
really is geared towards the person's
income so our rent levels are
based on how much a person makes the
20-acre lot will cater to low-income
families
and seniors nevada hand ceo audra
hammernick calls this particular
intersection an ideal spot to make it
happen
we have the health department we have
grocery stores retail business centers
there is public transportation within
walking distance and
really good access to the freeway thanks
to funding grants from the state
the city and several local lenders this
organization
hopes to help many struggling make ends
meet
it really is lasagna financing because
it takes all of these different players
to make sure that we're able to keep our
rents low
and those who live in the area call it a
step in the right direction
for this community's future i think it's
amazing we definitely need it
decatur commons is set to be done by
early next year depending on your income
units could start as low as around 400
dollars a month
now there is an interest list already
growing online we have a link to that
and more information for you on our
website
8newsnow.com reporting live tonight
sasha loftis
8 news now